the gyro can experience so have you
communicated with anybody that has any
thoughts on what what these things are
doing or whether or not there's any
consistency to the size of them or
whether or not they think they're coming
out of a larger object or anything along
these lines no you know you can ask well
because I was asking you know what do
you think they were doing you know and I
said you can look well they were
observing you know cuz they're coming
down and watching number two is they
were communicating because I think you
know in my heart I think there was
something under the water I don't you
know what it was doing there but because
of when you saw the X the crossed
looking yep thing explained that again
so the disturbance may be in the shape
of a cross yeah like I described it as
it's about the size of a 737 so I just
think if you submerge the 737 pointing
it to the east underwater by like you
know 10 15 feet so as these waves are
coming across when they you know they
hit that object they're gonna break on
top just like you would with a submerged
like a sea mount so and it's it's
they're breaking and that's where the
tic-tac was that that's the only reason
we saw the tic-tac that's what drew our
eyes down there as we see this
whitewater when it's a perfectly clear
day with no Whitecaps and you go whoa
what's that and then you see the tic-tac
and then we you know we do all the
chasing the tic-tac and we turn we're
right there and we turn around and
there's no white water it's just blue as
far as you can see so at that point you
go okay what was it doing because there
was obviously something there that's not
there now hmm so that's where I say well
it's it was observing us it was could
been communicating with or whatever was
there you know and then someone else
looked at me and said you know it's not
gonna loo and he goes what about
prepping the battlefield I go okay you
know so if you go you know or these
things from we don't know you know are
they from China Russia someplace else I
don't know but it's a it's a capability
that we do not possess to my knowledge
and if you asked me in 2004 cuz there's
a lot of guys go out maybe it's some
secret government program I
all right well let's let's let's be
honest one if you have a propulsion
system that made it gave the
capabilities that we observed visually
that's a huge leap for mankind' period
so you would say yeah it was you know
thinking about its it's gonna be fifteen
years next month
yeah that we saw this I would like to
think that okay maybe let's just say in
2004 it was something somebody had this
some government had this I don't ours
whatever
if you come to now you go fifteen years
later you don't think that technology
would have emerged because it would
literally would change everything we do
I mean we're happy about you know hybrid
and electric cars and all this other
stuff but if you've got something that
works like that err try it would change
our travel forever
no visible percent system of propulsion
no it no plumes no it's just we ask to
be jokey and said that's a think of a
40-foot long tic-tac that can move at
will through the air at speeds well
beyond what we've ever witnessed I mean
even when you watch a rocket go off you
know one of Ilan's or one of the NASA
whatever you know you sit there and I
grope during the Apollo ageism where you
just look at the thing go up up up up up
I've seen them shot out of Vandenberg we
go you know I'd sit in my house in
central California and you'd watch you
go up and go I can watch that thing for
a while this is something that just like
poof in a matter of seconds is gone now
our other pilots or other people that
have sighted these things have they also
reported something larger that's in the
water near it no no not the ones I've
talked to I mean I think you know you
can you can get on History Channel
there's all kinds of stuff on there
about people talking about stuff but you
know what here's the question is what do
you believe what you not believe and you
know my biggest frustration is you know
our incident and even the folks on the
East Coast it is what it is to us
there's no reason to embellish there's
no reason to make stuff up but yet
there's still groups of people that are
making stuff up like someone came out on
ours was talking about and he's like I I
saw the whole the whole video is 10
minutes long and it was doing all this
it's [ __ ] what you see is that's
literally the entire video it's a minute
and a half long I think it's about a
minute and a half
what people haven't seen that I saw I
mean I've seen the radar tapes because I
had them as my squadron you know I've
heard you know the men in black you know
I just I'm free you know maybe the okay
I'll give you the credit if they did but
why wouldn't they show up and talk to
the guys who actually witnessed it
chased it and is one of the senior guys
in that group right it's also possible
that that men and black stuff was
something they used to do back in the
day and that that program was no longer
continued and you know from Jeremy you
would know this the older sightings when
they go back into the day into
historical sightings and I'm not not
Columbus but you know a 50s and 60s did
they have similar things that they
talked about or something moved in this
manner yeah it's absolutely incredible
and I want to dumb this down because
that's how I had to understand it when I
was talking with commander for every
years before I kept his secret years
before the New York Times blew it up I
told him it's probably gonna happen it
wasn't by me we were talking about it
this system that we have seen for over
70 years just documented by our military
this is so important this is a non
reactionary field propulsion system
everything we know is a reactionary
propulsion system you push something out
the back it goes forward this is not
like a mag system this is a
gravitational field propulsion system
and throughout history our military has
documented them and there has been
ridiculed now I'll tell you exactly why
1952 there was a huge flyover of
Washington DC jets were scrambled all
the papers covered it's very famous you
know case everybody can look up it's an
important case because at that time a
policy was started and that policy
started because it crashed our
communications that teletypes went down
the panic of the UFOs that were being
seen by people with fighter pilots
trying to capture and trying to engage
them and and it crashed a teletypes so
our government was like oh that's not
happening again because you know russia
could use that as a scare tactic so this
policy of denial don't look here nothing
to see move on UFOs are fake
that's what Project Blue Book was tasked
to do specifically the guy who ran it it
mitad that that it was tasked to debunk
this and demystify the UFO thing that's
J Allen Hynek correct right I also yeah
jr. Hynek he was once asked by a friend
of mine do you have the smoking gun I'll
give you this document it's pretty
amazing it's an Air Force manual where
they explain what they know about UFOs
at that time in 1967 but here's the
point yes this has been going on since
the beginning of recorded human history
these propulsion systems that are
captured on footage you know that is
confirmed now by the net by the Pentagon
like commander flavors experience this
technology is not ours it's it was here
70 years ago you still my 15 years ago
we didn't we can hope we would see it
now these exact things at 20,000 miles
an hour going on 70 years ago documented
somebody has a non reactionary feel
propulsion system now are they aliens or
some subset of humans you know somebody
has them and they're flying through our
airspace with impunity and pilots like
commander flavor who by the way defended
Los Angeles over not after 9/11 I mean
this is a guy we put all of our trust in
he was defending Los Angeles right after
9/11 so we got people like him coming
forward saying I saw this and you got
Internet warriors being like it's a bird
it's a glitch it's Superman let's not
concentrate on them
[Applause]